at a briefing that was delayed for hours
eventually confirmation of what had been
feared for days
it's a hard day today as you know two
suicide bombers assessed to have been
isis fighters
detonated in the vicinity of the abbey
gate at hamad karzai international
airport and in the vicinity of the
barren hotel which is immediately
adjacent
the attack on the abbey gate was
followed by a number of isis gunmen who
opened fire on civilians and military
forces
at this time we know that 12 u.s service
members have been killed in the attack
and 15 more service members have been
injured
the general admitted that there was an
inevitability about the events in crowds
like this at some point the soldiers
come face to face with all those
arriving so we expect we we didn't we
thought this would happen sooner or
later it's tragic that it happened today
it's tragic there was this much loss of
life we are prepared to continue the
mission he revealed quite remarkably
that cooperation with the taliban now
goes as far as sharing intelligence we
share versions of this information with
the taliban so that they can actually do
some searching out there for us and we
believe that some attacks have been
thwarted by them but he was frank too on
the real prospect of another attack a
car bomb a suicide attack or even a
rocket against an aircraft full of
evacuees or troops and we are working
very hard right now to determine
attribution to determine who is
associated with this cowardly attack and
we're prepared to take action against
them but the core mission he said will
go on at the white house the president
has been out of sight behind this door
in the west wing in the situation room
he has spent days reflecting on his
decision to pull out in confronting the
critics on the chaos
i stand squarely behind my decision
it's time to end this war
i made the decision
the buck stops with me
this of course changes things for the
president profoundly with so many
questions political reputational
tactical does he retaliate or does he
retreat can he continue with an
evacuation that he justified because he
said the threat of terror had gone when
that has been proved so plainly wrong
and how will the american public react
to all this
his pledge was to bring troops out of
harm's way but a mission he ordered and
defended has now taken the lives of so
many more american and afghan